yeah I'm Lanie kenzo I'm a software
engineer i work on the product
infrastructure team at facebook and back
in january at react Jas comp to my
teammates dan Schaefer and jing chen
gave a talk introducing relay which is
our data fetching framework for react
and the query language that it uses
called graph ql so today in this talk
i'm going to start with a description of
relay engraft well for anyone who didn't
see their talk or who needs a refresher
and then i'm going to dive into some
specific parts of the real a framework
so let's start by thinking about how we
at facebook we're doing client
development a year ago at that point
we've developed react and we had also
developed the flux architecture which
provides a pattern for one-way data flow
through an application and when we use
both react and flux we found that we can
move faster in the development process
and we can build more robust reliable
applications but there was one big
problem that neither react nor flux
really addressed that almost every
client developer has faced at one time
or another which is what's the best way
to fetch data from the server and to
organize that data once it's on the
client so let's look at how data
fetching might work in an application
built with reactant flux I'm going to
use this example of a news feed story
that I wrote about Jay escon and in
particular its likes and comments
section on the bottom so this like and
comment box is was one of the first
parts of face book that we wrote with
reactant flux it's a really central part
of Facebook one where you get people
from a bunch of different teams coming
in and changing it frequently whether
they're updating the design or adding
new features so it's kind of a hot hot
part of Facebook so let's consider the
example of introducing stickers and
comments which is something that we
actually did last fall let's say that in
this part of the application our
component tree consists of this comment
box which contains a comment list which
contains a series of comment items so
how does each of these components get
the data that it needs the data comes
from the server and then it will get
past
through the component tree so comment
box is going to get some set of data and
then it will take a subset of that and
pass it into comment list and then
comment list will take subsets of that
data and pass that into each of the
comment items in this model the
important thing to notice is that every
component needs to be aware of the data
that its children need so that it can
pass the right data down and then that
server on point up there needs to be
aware of the data required by every
single component in that tree so in
other words the implementation details
of each component the details of what
exact data each component needs are
leaked up to the parents and to the
server why does this matter well it
means that if you come along and you
want to introduce sticker comments you
can't just make a change in comment item
you're also going to need to change
comment list comment box and that server
endpoint this is not cool when you need
to change all those files especially
when you have different people coming in
all trying to make their changes and
needing to modify all those files every
time you end up with more conflicts and
just generally slower development
process moreover things can get pretty
confusing when you have your data
fetching logic in one place on the
server and then you're rendering logic
on the client so let's say that you look
at your server endpoint and you see that
you're fetching the birthdays for all
the commenters on a story it's really
hard to know at a glance whether and
where this birthday data is being used
in your application on the client so
maybe someone ran an a/b test a few
months ago and they wanted to see what
would happen if they added birthdays for
commenters and it didn't really work
that well so they removed that code from
the client and now oops we have this
over fetching situation where we're
loading that birthday sending it to the
client and then we're not doing anything
with it and so it's just wasteful so
maybe we're going to try to do a good
deed and clean up the server remove that
birthday code without realizing that
there actually is some corner of
application where we're still using the
birthdays and now we have an under
fetching bug so we're going to send some
data the birthday won't be there and
things won't be good it's pretty easy to
for these data fetching pieces and the
and the rendered pieces
to get out of sync like this and it will
often cause either over fetching or
under fetching so how would this work in
a perfect world ideally if we wanted to
introduce sticker comments we would only
need to change that comment item
component and more generally rather than
having our data fetching logic strewn
throughout the application and on the
server you reside in just one place the
same place where we do our rendering
this is the idea at the core of relay
but to make development easier we should
keep our logic for data fetching and
rendering in the same place namely
within the react component so rather
than just containing the logic to render
itself like a traditional react
component a real a component also
contains a declaration of the data that
it needs in the form of a data query
this way when someone wants to make a
small change they can just find the
relevant component change its data query
and its render method and then they're
done you don't they don't need to go
change parent components or touch the
server with the data query and the
rendering in one place it's also a lot
easier to know when you're fetching data
that you don't don't use or trying to
use data that you didn't fetch so you're
less likely to get those over fetching
and under fetching bugs in order to
achieve all these benefits of putting
the data query in the component we
needed a common way for the components
to declare their data requirements and
this is where graph ql comes in graph UL
at the data queering language and for
the last couple years our client
applications at facebook have been using
graphs well to describe their data needs
let's look at an example of what a graph
ql query actually might look like so
let's let's think about the data that we
need to render a cup of comments author
here so we want yet the ID of the person
the person's name and then some data
that we need to render the profile
picture so look what happens if we
highlight just the fields here and
remove the values that's a graft well
query as you can see the query here it
not only expresses the data that it
needs but also the precise nested
structure that we want the response to
that query to have graph ql is designed
to be a thin layer over
existing data model so that clients can
get the benefit of writing queries like
this one without the whole server
needing to be totally rewritten another
important feature of reps well is that
you can compose queries so basically one
graph field query can be built up of
utter gaps filled queries so this means
that if you take a component tree like
this for an application on the one hand
you can look at it as a way to build a
view for the whole application so each
parent component will render its
children in the same way you can take
this component tree and look at it as a
guide for how to build the graph ql
query for the whole application each
parent components graph GL query is
composed from the queries of its
children so now that you see what graft
well is we can look at how relay works
overall each relay component contains
this query and the render method relays
going to take the queries from each
component and build up that overall
query and send that to the server the
server is going to respond and then
really puts our response data into a
single store and then it will use that
data to construct prop that it sends out
to the components for rendering at its
core this is a flux application the only
difference is that rather than having
several or many stores a relay
application just has this one single
store containing generic logic for
dealing with graft well data having this
single store provides a number of nice
benefits so for one it reduces the need
for a lot of the flux boilerplate it
also helps with data consistency across
different parts of the application and
finally it lets us build certain common
product pattern something like pagin
aiding through a list of items something
that you guys have probably implemented
at least one right into relay so that
people don't need to build them from
scratch every time so now that we see
how really works let's look back at this
sticker common example and see how much
easier relay is going to make our lives
rather than needing to change a bunch of
files up the whole tree and the server
we just changed comment item so more
specifically let's say that this is part
of our graphical query right now we're
just putting for the text of the comment
and now we can also
with a sticker use that in our render
method and we're done we can go build
other awesome stuff in the time that we
would have spent changing those other
files so really solves this big problem
of how to fetch data in a way that we
found scales really nicely to a complex
application being developed by a big
engineering team so because you have
that data query and the render method
encapsulated within the component it's
easy for a lot of people to work on a
lot of different parts of an application
at once so I can make my changes my
teammates can make their changes people
on other teams can make their changes
and we don't need to worry as much about
whether we're stepping on each other's
toes and whether we have full context on
what every other person is doing at that
time so far you've heard about the read
path and relay but a framework would be
would have limited usefulness if it
didn't also support a right path if it
didn't let developers give users a way
to take actions that does liking a story
maybe even liking my own story so I'll
use the term mutations to refer to these
actions that a user can take in an
application so in facebook this could be
something like sharing a link our suit
came to an event or poking a friend and
for the rest of the talk I'll focus on
how mutations work in relay so to start
I'm going to go back and talk about how
we at facebook at least we're building
mutations before relay so I joined
facebook a little over three years ago
and I was working on the newsfeed
product team mostly working on the
homepage of the website and i got really
familiar with writing mutations like
this i would write some custom
JavaScript and I would write a custom
server on point I would have the
JavaScript called that in point I would
have the endpoint return data and
basically whatever format I chose then I
would have the JavaScript make sense of
that data and update the views
accordingly usually by manually updating
the DOM and then maybe I wanted to also
use that same endpoint from a different
part of the client I would need to shove
some more messy logic in there to make
sure that the server was returning the
data that the client needed regardless
of where it was being called from and
the key word here is custom basically
every time my team major I wanted to
implement a new mutation we had to start
from scratch
I personally really disliked this
pattern of writing mutations with these
custom endpoints and custom client code
if I'll really repetitive an error prone
to me and in my mind this pattern became
kind of synonymous with writing
JavaScript because I had just started a
Facebook I came right out of school this
is what I did every time I would write
JavaScript so to me this was JavaScript
and so I came to think of myself as
someone who really didn't like
JavaScript and didn't want to write it
it wasn't until I was introduced to
react and flux that I started to realize
that I don't dislike JavaScript I just
like this kind of gross pattern of using
it so I wouldn't have guessed three
years ago that I would be now on a team
where I'm writing JavaScript full-time
or here with all of you guys but a
JavaScript conference but here I am and
I'm pretty excited about it so back to
mutations we we took a step in the right
direction when we introduced a more
structured API for doing rights as part
of our graph API so this was nice
because it gave the client a
standardized way to specify what
mutation they wanted to do and also to
provide the necessary inputs in a
structured way but what about the data
that that the server returns then each
right endpoint in the graph API is being
used by a bunch of different clients
there's not really a great way to make
sure that the server is going to return
the data that any client might need to
update itself so what we would do
instead is usually provide these pretty
minimal responses usually just an ID so
maybe if it was the mutation was writing
a comment we will just return the idea
of the new comment or maybe even just a
boolean saying this mutation succeeded
or it did and so at that point there's
two main options for how you update the
client you can guess you can say okay I
got this boolean things worked so this
is how I think the data should look now
or you could do a second round trip go
back to the server and get the data that
you need if you want to be really sure
that it's right the first option has
issues with correctness potentially and
the second has issues with efficiency so
neither one of those is really ideal
ideally the response from the server
would contain exactly the information
that the client needs top date itself so
let's talk about liking a story let's
say we have this mobile client and it
shows the number of people who
like the story then we would want the
server if you did a like to return the
new light count so that we could update
the story correctly in our web client
instead of just showing the number of
likes we show this thing that we call
the like sentence and it's it's an
internationalized string that we
generate on the server that provides
some social context about who else who
who of your friends or who has liked the
story so for this we would want the
server to actually return the new like
sentence so that we could do the update
okay but then what if we wanted to
change the mobile client to also show
the profile pictures of the likers then
we would want to make sure to update the
server so that it also returns the new
likers picture so that we can show that
when someone likes it and then maybe if
eventually we took out those pictures we
would need to clean up that server
endpoint get rid of the liker picture
and this situation should start feeling
kind of familiar to you it's similar to
what we saw with data reads where we're
in that situation where the server
endpoint needed to be aware of the
details of the clients rendering logic
when we change the client rendering we
need to change what we return from the
right endpoint on the server and it gets
kind of tough and time-consuming to keep
those two places in sync just like
before relay and graphs well can help us
solve the problem so it turns out the
graph ql doesn't just support doing data
reads it also supports right graph ql
mutations so how will this work and
graph ql if you want to do a dick read
you just provide a query and you get a
response mutations are a little
different so you need to provide three
piece of information the type of the
mutation that you're trying to do any
inputs that will usually just be an ID
or two and then a query for the data
that you want after that mutation has
been performed so for liking a story
what would this be the type is just
story like the inputs that you need to
give our just the idea of the story that
your liking and then the query can be
anything but in this case let's say we
want to know if the viewer likes the
story so you know if you should make
that little thumb blue and then the
count of the number of people that like
it so when we send this information to
graft well it performs the right and
then it runs that query and then it will
send us back this payload which we can
use
to update the client relay uses graph ql
mutations for all of its data rights
which provides a standardized way to
both perform the rites and then to
update the client afterwards but let's
look back at these three pieces of
information here one of the more
interesting problems that we face when
developing this mutations framework for
relay was how to decide what this query
should actually be so our goal here was
to get the client data consistent with
the new post mutation state of the world
so we want this query to be for anything
that we had in the store in our in relay
that could have changed as a result of
the mutation happening so one option the
easiest option is just to have the
developer write these crazy manually so
in this example they would write this
query but then let's say someone came
and added profile pictures here we would
send this information to the server the
right would happen we would get this
response back and we wouldn't have the
new profile picture in the right size
and and this would be a bug so to avoid
that the person who added the profile
pictures would need to make sure to go
find that mutation query probably
somewhere in some other file and add the
profile picture in there and more
generally we would be in this situation
where every time someone changed some
rendering logic they would need to
remember to go find all of the
potentially relevant mutation queries
and change them this wasn't a great
option for us since with relay we really
want to minimize these situations where
you make a change somewhere and then you
need to make a change in a bunch of
other places so instead we put the logic
to determine the correct mutation query
into relay itself how does this work so
intrinsic to every graph ql mutation is
the set of data that can change as a
result of that mutation so this is an
independent of what any client renders
it's a property of the mutation itself
so it's a property of story like or a
comment create so here's the set of
things that can change when we do a
story like and if we always queried for
everything that can change every time we
did a mutation we would clearly end up
in a consistent state but we might be
massively over fetching since maybe we
never rendered any of
data we don't care about some of them so
we have relied keep track for each ID of
the set of data that the client has
retrieved for that ID and put into its
store so if we had rendered my story
maybe this would be the set of the data
that we have fetched for my story and
then when you do a mutation on some
story or on some ID really builds a
mutation query by intersecting this set
of things that can possibly change with
the set of things that it knows that it
cares about the set of things that it
has in a store this ensures that we
query for exactly the set of field that
needs to be updated so in this case we
would end up with this query here and
the really nice part of this is that if
someone does come along and let's say
they replace that three likes with the
like sentence then relay this what we've
stored will know that we've now fetched
the like sentence for that story not the
Lakers count and so when we do this
intersection the intersected query will
be the correct one will correctly ask
the server for the new like sentence
rather than the like count so those are
the basics of how relay mutations work
the user takes an action we send the
name of the mutation and any inputs into
relay and really does that intersection
to figure out what the query should be
it'll send that over to the server the
server will respond will put that
response into the store and then we'll
notify the affected views by sending
them updated crops and you'll notice
that this diagram is kind of similar to
the one I showed you for the read path
before in particular the second part is
identical in the two flows graph ql
sends us some data relay puts it in the
store and then we send the props to the
components these parallels between the
read and the right flows are not a
coincidence just like flux relay treats
data rights as first-class citizens by
using the same core logic and code to
handle both reads and writes so if
you've written mutations before you'll
know that even when you have v1 working
when you have the right actually
happening on the server and then the
client getting updated correctly there's
there's often a lot more
to be done so maybe you have to think
about things like making that feel more
responsive by having the client kind of
doing fake updates instantaneously or
you have to worry about how to handle
errors timeout retries or things like
race conditions because relay has this
centralized mutations framework we're
able to take a lot of these common
concerns and put them into relay itself
so the developers get that get the
handling of those issues for free rather
than needing to solve them again and
again with each new mutation so let's
start with that app responsiveness
example if I implement its story like
the way that I've described so far and
then someone use this app and hit the
like button they notice a significant
delay between when they hit like and
when one app actually changes because
we're sitting there waiting for the
server response to come back waiting for
that graphical response it would be nice
if we didn't have to deal with this
delay and lucky for us really provide
support for what we call optimistic
mutations where we immediately update
the view to the expected post right
state being optimistic that everything
will work out nicely on the server
essentially to make this happen you can
provide a payload mimicking the server
response and then the view will change
instantly based on that payload so that
optimistic payload doesn't have to
include everything that would be in the
server update it can include as much or
as little information as you need to
make things feel right so it's kind of
just a we want this to feel good in
between when we're waiting for the
server response to come back so maybe
for story like we would just do an
optimistic peeled like this just slip
does viewer like to true and that would
cause the the thumb to turn blue
immediately but maybe you'd think this
is kind of weird because you still see
to like so you could do this instead is
optimistic payload we're now you're also
incrementing the count by one so that
you'll get the three likes and the blue
thumb instantly if I had wanted to do an
optimistic update like this back when I
was writing mutation for the newsfeed
team I would need to just add a bunch of
code to manually update the Dom in a
react application i could call us at
state to get my component to rerender
with this new optimistic data but in
really i just provide this optimistic
tailored and then everything else
happens automatically the framework
automatically will update the views
so I want to describe now how these
optimistic mutations have been behind
the scenes even though the view is
changing immediately with optimistic
update really isn't immediately
overriding the data in that graph you'll
store so instead we maintain a queue of
in-flight mutations mutations that we've
done the optimistic update but the
server response hasn't come back yet and
when we read data from the store we read
through that Q so what does that look
like let's say that this is the data in
our store for my story so the UI is
going to reflect what we have in the
store and then let's say I do alike so
you'll notice that the UI block
immediately changed blue but the store
we haven't changed anything in the store
yet and now I do a comment again because
of the optimistic update the UI changes
instantly but the store is still
untouched so now we get the server
payload let's say the like succeeded
this is when will actually remove that
like from the queue and update the store
so now what if we get an error for the
comment so if we had immediately written
that comment into the store when as soon
as I did it this is when we would be in
a little bit of a sticky situation
because we need to kind of roll back our
changes make sure that we left the store
in the exact state that it had been
before but because we maintain this
queue all you need to do is remove it
from the queue the stores still in good
shape and the UI goes back to taking the
comment away the mutations q also makes
it simple to deal with retries so let's
say that I'm trying to comment and say
thanks to my friends here so I hit post
and the optimistic update happens
immediately and is added to the queue
and then an error comes back so in the
example I just showed you I took them I
just said okay there was an error take
it out of the queue revert but what we
can also do is keep it in the queue but
mark it with an error state and the view
can pick up on this air state and show
that little message unable to post
comment try again and then if I do hit
try again it's easy to perform that
retry since we have that comment
mutation sitting in the queue and it
contains all the data that it needs to
basically send itself off to the server
again so I hit retry and this time it
works and voila
so a final nice feature of relay
mutations framework is that it provides
a solution for race conditions that you
can get when someone is performing a
quick sequence of mutations on all
affecting the same object so let's say
that I quickly like and unlike my story
a bunch of times in a row there's a
pretty high chance here that something's
going to go wrong if we just didn't have
any special casing for the situation so
there's a race condition for my
mutations hitting the server if the if
I've ended up on an unlike but the like
is the last one hit the server then
we're going to have the wrong state of
data on the server and even if that all
works out we have another race condition
for those payloads coming back where
it's the last one that comes back is the
like then we're going to have an
inconsistent State on the client in
relay we have a way to detect the view
mutations are dependent and guarantee
that only one of them is in flight at a
time so the first one goes off and only
when that payload comes back do we send
off the second one and so on so all the
optimistic rights still happen
immediately so the person using the
application doesn't know that we're
doing anything different behind the
scenes but we do this thing to ensure
that we're not going to get these
collisions so all what I've described so
far relay and its mutations framework
are already being used in a few places
in production at Facebook including our
standalone groups app and our mobile ads
manager app which are both using both
relay and react native I'm going to
spend the last few minutes here
discussing a part of relay that we're
still working on that's not yet in
production so this was a diagram that I
showed earlier to explain mutations as i
explained really can take this mutation
payload from graft well store it and
then send the props to any effective
views so here the action is originating
from the person who's using the
application but that doesn't have to be
the case so imagine if Joe comments on
my story from his phone we can actually
use this same path once it goes through
the cloud to send his mutation payload
to relay put it in the store and then
update the views to show his new comment
do we call this a subscription
basically if I'm looking at a new speed
story I can subscribe to all new
comments happening on that story and at
the time that i subscribe i'll provide a
graph to all queries saying here's the
query for what data i want for every new
comment that comes in and then using a
pub sub system in the back end we can
ensure that all of these mutation
payloads for each new comment are
delivered whenever someone comments and
then relay will automatically update the
views so along the same lines I've say
media or firebase this subscriptions
piece of relay provides a simple way to
build dynamic applications that feel
alive with real-time updates and this is
something that we're excited about
integrating into various parts of
facebook so I'm going to close with just
a few last points the core idea of relay
just to re-emphasize that is that we
should keep our data fetching logic
together with our rendering logic within
each component because we found this
approach to really scale well to a big
application being built by a big team
one of our main goals when we've
designed really has been to identify
these problematic patterns that people
are facing again and again and that are
slowing them down and pull the
complexity of those patterns into relay
so we saw a few examples of this today
with relay mutations from the way that
we do that intersection to determine the
correct mutation query to the way that
we have optimistic updates in that queue
to our solution for rage conditions in
each case someone using relay will get
these common problems solved for free
and can focus on bigger and better
things so I'm going to close with one
last sticker comment thank you all for
listening
you